ja hallo klickom hallo Thomas
D zunächst mal großes Lob an klickom für
die tollen Interviews und ich hoffe dass
er noch lange so weitermcht ja meine
Frage an
TD es gibt einige Rapper die mit dem
Alter aufgehört haben zu rappen und ich
sag mal ruhigere Musik abgedürftet sind
z.B Max dürf bekannt
sein denkst du noch im Schaukelstuhl auf
deiner Veranda zu sitzen auf dem Mars
und zu Wappen oder würdest du dich auch
ja in die ruhigere Musik zurückziehen
und ja das ist eigentlich so meine Frage
ich habe tatsächlich diese Vision von
der Veranda und ich habe mir mal vor
Jahren schon eine Mandoline gekauft
Marilyn mandolin heißt die dies
wunderschöne Ovation Mandoline die ich
irgendwann noch spielen lernen will und
dann in diesem schaukelstuh auf der
Veranda mit mit Füße auf der auf dem
Geländer Holz auch schon guter Lack ab
beim D und allem auch hier in der
Veranda und dann spiele ich diese
Marilyn mandolin und da werde ich dann
wahrscheinlich eher so ein bisschen
Blues dazu singen was ich nicht kann
oder Blues Rap oder ich glaube schon
dass ich meine Musik auch mit mir
wandeln wird und ich vielleicht später
dann allein wenn der Isas ist nicht mehr
zulässt zu hüpfen dann auch ruhigere
Musik machen werde ich glaube es kommt
so ein do auf comes natural man fängt an
mit wildem anarchozeug und kommt dann
irgendwann in SE seinen Bereich und
verlässt den dann vielleicht und
verwandelt sich in den etwas vielleicht
auch spoken word ich hoffe ich werde
immer noch denken können und diese
Gedanken zum Ausdruck bringen in Form
von kleinen Songs wie sich die anhören W
wir abwarten
müssen